another wrong way driving crash just two
weeks after a former eight news now
employee lost his life from a wrong way
driver it happened yesterday afternoon
on the 215 near Durango endot says
they're adding more prevention
technology in the coming months but how
effective is it and if intoxication is a
factor of course Ryan Matthew
took us into ndot today he joins us live
in the Northeast Valley tonight
Denise Bryan we
met the wife of our former colleague was
just released from the hospital this
week she was the passenger in that crash
about two weeks ago and that was on the
southern portion of the 215 Beltway that
takes us to to yesterday last night here
on the Northern portion of the 215
Beltway with that wrong way crash it's a
growing problem says ndot with growing
solutions they add but those solutions
could not come soon enough
a wrong way crash in the midst of Rush
Hour Nevada state police reporting
Wednesday a female driver of a white
Nissan crashed head-on with a male
driver of a gray truck the mail driver
sent to the hospital the female wrong
way driver surviving and believed to be
intoxicated and calling it an epidemic
at this point that's NSB Sergeant Jason
brocheck two weeks ago when 8 news now
first reported on this fatal wrong way
crash year after year he says the number
of wrong-way driving incidents in the
valley growing
though it's unclear where the most
recent driver entered the freeway it
likely wasn't here U.S 95 and Durango
the only location in the Las Vegas
Valley to have ndot wrong way driving
technology flashing lights and video
sent to First Responders meant to get
wrong way drivers to turn around it's
really hard to engineer your way out of
somebody driving drunk or high Justin
Hopkins ndot spokesperson says more of
this technology is coming by the summer
a three-year study revealing 85 percent
of Wrong Way drivers Statewide turned
around when they saw this but as to if
intoxicated drivers will actually notice
it we hope that these systems will not
necessarily stop someone from driving
impaired but will stop them from getting
on the freeway going in the wrong
direction when they are impaired
now he adds the new locations were
chosen since they're some of the newest
builds meaning the infrastructure is
already in place to build them also
meaning it's the cheapest locations to
build a map he adds new locations could
be chosen in the coming years but that
all depends on funding reporting live
over the 215 at Durango Ryan Matthey 8
News Now